the following game was my favorite of
the ones I saw in the match between
alpha zero and starfish and the reason
why is likely because it remind me most
of a human game I felt like I was
sitting and watching Magnus Carlsen
slowly outplay another elite player in a
position that was slightly better for
white but probably shouldn't have been
winning now I think that goes to show
perhaps that stock fish thought that the
valuation was level that there was no
real risk of losing but at a certain
moment alpha zero was able to break
through and thus achieve a victory
so tonight f3 and I have six and we see
a symmetrical English where alpha zero
fianchetto is the bishop now black
played Queen to b6 a bit strange because
oftentimes black wants to play b6 father
died with Bishop to be seven and
challenged on this long diagonal but
Queen b6 has other intentions it's just
to play for d5 for black and to stop d4
for white because you know it's harder
to play this move with the Queen on the
b6 square so d3 saying I'm not going for
d4 don't worry d5 Bishop to Bishop e7
and okay we clarified the action in the
center now pawn takes e4 here would be a
big mistake because after pawn takes e4
pawn takes e4 now White has the four on
three on the Kings side and the one on
zero in the center so II five is the
threat to kick the night away from f6
follow that up with Knight to d5 and
white is clearly making advances in the
position that are uncomfortable for
blacks to deal with so taking is not an
option so d4 is played and okay the
position is probably about level maybe
slightly better for white is the opening
ninety five takes takes and what this
trade is done is given white doubled
isolated pawns the D file but also given
this Bishop a longer diagonal to work
with that's sort of thematic in lines
like this where this and I can swing
around say to the c-4 square and also
annoy the Queen on b6 so castles castles
Bishop g4 that Knight to c4 idea was
really annoying
that's why Bishop g4 is played and h3
takes takes and
now d6 is one of those moves we're like
okay let me open up my bishop I have a
light square bishop my opponent doesn't
let me improve my position but it
actually doesn't lead to an advantage
because after Bishop d6 Queen b7 just
simply rook to b8 and this pawn is quite
weak as well so you have the two bishops
advantage but don't really have ways to
take advantage thus far so it's just
having two bishops rather than a true
advantage so instead after Knight a 6h 4
which is a great move by the way
just going for expansion on the Kings
side and look at blacks position there
aren't pieces on that side of the board
the nights over there on a6 the Queen's
on the Queen Sun and b6 and the position
says all zeroes look at that evaluation
bar that's chest comp server using the
stock fish engine to evaluate so stock
fish with the black pieces thanks
equality but you know there needs to be
more depth on the engine to clarify the
evaluation but that's what it says and I
don't believe it I think Y is just
better and after age 5 you put black in
a tough spot because if you play h6
which stops the pawns advance that's
square for white then you have issues
immediately with Queen to f5 and once
queen of five happens Bishop before is
the follow-up and that Queen's getting
to h7 whether you like it or not and
well you really won't like it
so black does not play h6 after age 5
and said plays Queen to d8 and h6 g6 so
clear holes in blacks position if I can
get Queen to f6 I'm threatening Queen g7
checkmate this pawn and h6 does really
well to keep blacks King feeling unsafe
so white is trying to improve the
position Bishop d2 finally connecting
the rooks in a5 black is stopping any
potential white play on the Queen side
and also may be thinking about play of
its own right your stock fish can get b5
in then just continue making progress
and that's how the board perhaps you can
get some kind of active counter play
there but that's why a 4 was played if
you ever play b5 right at this point
ever it touches the square I'm going to
capture it and then you're a 5 pawn
feels very
weeks so you don't really want to play
move d5 and instead b6 was played rookie
to rookie and since this rook is not
connected to the other rook now you can
capture on e8 and play rook to e1 rook
b8 b3 just to make sure that the Queen
side is totally closed Knight c7 and
okay rookie - so what is not really
doing too much right now but trying to
find an opportune moment to make
progress any sort of pawn move for black
is very compromising for example if you
ever touch this pawn on f7 and go to f5
then you leave this big hole on the e6
square right and it move like Bishop f4
also is just gonna be strong where all
of these squares around blacks King feel
very loose and easy to take advantage of
for white so you can't play f5 that
means your king is stuck with back rank
problems as well
so besides shuffle a little bit
Bishop h3 well that has to be a good
move because you're getting Bishop went
to an open diagonal rather than on this
close one with the pawn on d5 blockading
it and both sides are just maneuvering
back and forth now it's certainly worth
mentioning that Knight takes d5 is not a
good move because white retreats this
rook to e1 and now after this Knight
moves say back to c7 the White Queen
enters via c6 right so you've given up a
pawn to improve the positions
demonstrating that the quality of your
pieces is more important than the
quantity when you're just giving up a
pawn in fact White has a humongous
advantage and you can see that in the
evaluation bar so instead of taking that
pawn rook b8 was played we're going back
to one and still they're just moving and
maneuvering and rook to e5 now to
protect this pawn on d5 it's a bishop
back rook e1 and right about now we
finally see progress with Bishop f4 so
it was a timing thing White was going
back and forth to time everything
correctly and the point is if these
bishops get traded then the dark squares
feel much weaker right you
so Queen d7 G for I like this move a lot
why would you trade on d6 because it's
not like black wants to trade on F for
anyway
so G forces please take me here because
once my queen takes on f4 my queen is
just one step closer to check meeting
you on this g7 square so rook e8 perhaps
thinking that exchanging pieces leaves
black closer to a draw and the engine
evaluation is still the bar is at zero
but when I see a position like this I
just love White's chances and rookie
four please please please be incorrect
inaccurate and take me because once I
take with this pawn now all of a sudden
I'm making progress and you can't stop
right it's imminent and unavoidable so
this would be just terrible and you see
the evaluation bar reflecting that so
you can't take me on e4
so black chooses rook d8 and now Bishop
g5 hitting that rook on d8 and look at
this Queen f6 well matin one is the
threat only one way to stop it Bishop f8
and finally progress has really been
made with Queen to c6 you have to trade
Queens
if you move your queen to c8 you have a
problem with this night being pinned so
I take your rook you can't take with a
knight because it spins at the Queen and
after Queen takes the 8th I simply take
your knight on c7 that's disastrous so
Queen c6 forces the Queen trade and
after this Queen trade now I have a
passed pawn on c6 it's not about undoing
the pawns that's not the important part
it's about how advanced that passed pawn
is and black has no real movement to
make so Bishop d6 was played f4 and look
how simple and straightforward this is
King f8 f5 well if you don't have any
other moves you sort of have to take me
because if you play the move Bishop to
e7 I'm not gonna trade you on e7 I
probably could and just get away with it
but I also can just retreat this Bishop
to the f4 square and challenge your
knight on c7 and if you try to protect I
keep going forward with f6 and these are
very concrete tactical points here
Bishop f6 I throw in this check first
too
take your king away from the defense of
the e8 square and once you come to g8
now I take on c7 saying that please take
my bishop on c7 because rook e8 will be
made so of course that's not happening
and after f5g takes f5 happened but now
there's a big problem and that big
problem at the h7 pawn because look how
quickly white finishes off this game f6
not your king has to go back over to GA
to protect and you're tied down so after
Bishop f5 the plan is simple go bring
this Kingdom G to bring this King to e4
make the progress you need the black
king is stuck protecting h7 the Black
Knight is stuck blockading the c6 pawn
so look look how this game finishes here
you can't take on f6 because I just
simply take you and you may think Oh
drawing chances opposite colored bishops
but of course c7 c8 equals Queen is not
just you're getting a queen it's
probably mating and it just a couple
moves and that's why the evaluation say
says mate in seven so taken f6 and not
possible okay what Bishop c7 doesn't
help and Bishop f4 trading the Bishop's
point at large
Knight is stuck defending the C pawn and
on the other hand the King is stuck
protecting h7 so Knight takes f6 does
nothing to save you and in fact the game
ended after king of four because my King
just goes and wins like this King can go
to f6 now and this King on e8 is
overwhelmed you go this way I'm going to
win this H pawn here and push my own
pawn so just completely winning in game
so a very nice demonstration by alpha
zero playing positional chest they're
getting a grip on the position that
stockfish seemed to indicate that it was
holding but alpha zero had other
intentions and seeing very deep that the
sort of paralysis in the position was in
fact breakable and thus a win for alpha
zero just the final position once more
there was no Knight takes f6 in fact the
game was over here because King stuck to
H pawn and the white king is coming in